The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
NANCY KANWISHER: I'll
just be brief today,
but you can check out some of my
stuff at the website up there.
If you're confused
by my appearance,
if you've met me before, yes,
I used to look like that.
But at a deeper level,
really, I look like this.
This is me, and you look
like that, too, inside.
And these are parts
of-- is that showing?
Yeah.
These are parts of
my brain that we've
mapped with functional MRI
that were either discovered
in my lab, or that my
colleagues discovered,
and that we then ran-- they're
kinds of scans in my lab.
These are all regions that do
very specific things and that
to me, are a big part of the
story of how we are so smart.
So my interests, at
a very general level,
are to answer things like
what is the architecture
of the human mind?
What are its
fundamental components?
And there are lots
and lots of ways
to find those
fundamental components.
Functional MRI, which is
how we made this picture,
is just one of a huge number.
I loved Patrick's comment that
you should find questions, not
hammers.
I kind of like my hammer,
I have to confess.
But questions are
more important.
And there are lots
of ways to approach
this question of the basic
architecture of the human mind.
I also want to know
how this structure,
which is present in
every normal person--
I could pop any of
you in the scanner
and make a picture like
this of your brain, OK,
it would take a little while,
but wouldn't take that long.
How does that structure
arise over development?
How does your genetic
code and your experience
work together to
wire that up when
you're an infant and a child?
How did it evolve
over human evolution?
This is sort of what's sometimes
called a mesoscale, this really
macroscopic picture of the major
components of the human mind
and brain.
But of course, we also want
to know how each of those bits
work.
What are the
representations that
live in each of those regions?
And how are they computed?
And what are the
neural circuits that
implement those computations?
And of course, cognition
doesn't happen in just one
little machine in there.
It's a product of all of
these bits working together.
We want to understand how
all of that works, too,
and how all of that goes
together to make us so smart.
And that's related to a question
that I'm deeply interested in,
which is what is so special
about this machine that looks
a lot like a rodent brain?
And it's smaller than a whale
brain or a Neanderthal brain,
so it's not just that
we have more of it.
What is so special about this
thing that has put all of us
here, interacting
with each other
and studying this
thing, something
that no other brain is doing,
no other species brain?
So are there special bits?
Do those bits work differently?
Are there special
kinds of neurons?
I don't think so,
some people do.
What is it about this that
has brought us all right here?
OK, so that, at a top level,
are some of the questions
I would most like to answer.
Not that I know how to
approach any of them,
but I think it's important to
keep an eye on those goals,
even when you don't quite see
how you're going to get there.
My particular focus
in the CBMM Project
is to look at social
intelligence, which
is one piece of that puzzle.
And so, why social intelligence?
Well, just briefly, I
think social cognition
is in many ways the crux
of human intelligence.
OK, and it's a crux in a whole
bunch of different senses.
One is it's just the source
of how we're so smart.
Like, if you think about
all the stuff you know,
OK, do a quick mental inventory.
OK, what's all the
stuff you know?
Like, make a little taxonomy.
There's this kind of
stuff, it's all lots
of different kinds
of stuff you know.
OK, now how much of
that stuff that you
know would you know
if you had never
interacted with another person?
A lot of it, you
wouldn't know, right?
So a lot of the stuff we
know and a lot of the ways
that we're smart
are things that we
get from interacting
with other people.
That's social cognition.
OK.
Another sense in
which social cognition
is the crux of
human intelligence
is many people think that the
primary driver of the evolution
of the human brain has
been the requirement
to interact with
other people who are,
after all, very
complex entities,
and to be able to understand
how to work with them,
and what they're
doing, and what they'll
do next is very
cognitively demanding.
And so that may be one of the
major forces that has driven
the evolution of our brain.
Another sense in which
social intelligence
is the crux of
human intelligence
is that it's just plain a large
percent of human cognition.
OK, so we do versions of social
cognition much of every day.
Right now, I'm having
these thoughts in my head.
God knows what that
looks like neurally.
I'm translating that into some
noises that are coming out
of my mouth, you're
hearing those noises,
and you're getting-- let's
hope-- kind of similar thoughts
in your head.
That is a miracle.
Nobody has the foggiest idea how
that works at a neural level.
Nobody can even make up
a sketch of a hypothesis
of a bunch of neural
circuits that might
be able to make that happen.
Right?
That's a fascinating
puzzle, and it's also
of the essence in
human intelligence.
And we do it all the time,
not just speaking per se,
but all the other ways
that we share information
with each other.
So one, social
cognition is just what
we do all day long every day.
It's also a big part of the
surface area of the cortex.
So this cartoon here shows--
with some major poetic
license--
brain regions that are
involved in different aspects
of social cognition.
And it's just a big part of
the cortical area as well.
OK.
Another sense in
which social cognition
is of the essence in
human intelligence
is that many of the greatest
things that humanity
has accomplished are products
of people working together.
So all of that is
the big picture
on why social cognition is cool,
and important, and fundamental.
The part of it that we're
focusing on in our thrust
within this NSF
grant is something
I call social perception.
OK, so by social
perception, I mean
this spectacularly
impressive human ability
to extract rich,
multidimensional
social information from a
brief glimpse of a scene.
From a brief
glimpse at a person,
you can tell not just who
that person is, you can
tell what they're trying to do.
You can tell how they feel.
You can tell what they're
paying attention to.
You can tell what they
know and who they like.
OK?
And that's just the beginning.
So the work in our
thrust tries to approach
all of these different
kinds of questions
that we are calling as part
of our PR of this NSF grant.
It's kind of an
organizing principle.
The Turing questions,
these demanding, difficult
computational problems
of social perception.
Who is that person?
What are they
paying attention to?
What are they feeling?
What are they like?
Are they interacting
with somebody?
What is the nature
of that interaction?
And so on.
OK?
So the general plan
of action in how
to approach this
in our thrust is
first to study these abilities
in the computational system
that's best at them,
namely this one--
and those out
there, yours, too--
the human brain.
And so the roadmap here is
to first do psychophysics,
characterize simple
behavioral measurements--
what can people do,
what can't they do--
from simple stimuli, and
quantify that in detail.
Ask, how good are we at it?
Maybe some of these things
that we think we can do, like
size up somebody's
personality in three seconds
when we first meet them--
feels like you can
do that, or at least
you get a read on them--
I mean, is that
based on anything?
Is that just garbage?
Right?
Are we actually tapping
into real information there?
What cues are we using when
we make those high level
social inferences?
What is the input
that we get, that we
use as a basis for analyzing
this particular percept
or throughout life
that we've used
to train up our brains
to be able to do this?
So the second approach is once
we have some kind of sense
of what are those abilities--
that's sometimes called Marr
theory level, characterizing
what can we do, right--
is we can then try to
computationally model this.
And so there's lots of
different ways to do this,
and many of the other thrusts
that you'll hear about
are really tackling
that problem.
Another thing we can
do is, of course,
characterize the brain
basis of these abilities,
and we can do that with
all kinds of methods.
We're using, in our
thrust, functional MRI,
intracranial recordings,
something called NIRS.
This is the ability to make
measurements of blood flow
changes in very young infants.
And so we can characterize
these brain systems
in adults and infants.
And that gives you a
leg up in understanding
these other broader
questions about how
the whole system works in
a number of different ways.
Just seeing how
the brain carves up
the problem of social
perception into pieces
already gives you some
clues about the kinds
of computations that may go
on in each of those pieces.
OK?
OK.
So that's the overview.
There's many, many
ways you can do this,
and of course, people all
over the place are doing this.
There's nothing all
that unique about it.
This is just our framework here.
Some of the specific
projects that are going on
include some work on face
recognition, which of course,
a really classic
question that many people
have been approaching.
My post-doc, Matt Peterson, here
has done some very lovely work
where he's shown that, actually,
where you look on a face
is very systematic.
You don't just look
anywhere, right?
When you first make us
saccade into a face,
somebody appears in your visual
periphery, right, of course,
all the high-resolution visual
abilities are all right near
the center of gaze
around the fovea,
where you have a high density of
photo receptors and a shitload
of cortex-- to be
technical about it--
devoted to allocating
center of gaze.
Right back here, in primary
visual cortex and with
the first few
retinotopic regions,
you have 20 square
centimeters-- that's like that--
of cortex allocated to just the
central two degrees of vision.
Right?
So you have a lot of
computational machinery doing
just that bit right there.
Well, when a face appears
in your periphery,
you move that bit of
your cortex, boom,
right on top of it.
So you have all that
computational machinery
to dig in on the face, right?
OK, so what Matt has shown
is that the particular way
that you allocate that
computational machinery, namely
by making an eye movement
to put that stimulus
right on your fovea, people
do that slightly differently.
Some people fixate
on a face up here,
some people fixate
on a face down there,
and most people fixate
someplace in the middle.
OK?
Well, so why is it interesting?
Here's why it's interesting.
People do that in
very systematic ways.
And if you look up
here, you pretty much
always look up there.
And if you look down there,
you pretty much always
look down there.
And this has computational
consequences.
If we brought you
guys into the lab
and ran you on an eye
tracker for 15 minutes,
we'd find out which
of you look up there
and which of you
look down there.
And if we took those of
you who look up here,
and we presented a face
by flashing it briefly
while you're fixating
so that the face landed
in your not-preferred
looking position,
your accuracy at
recognizing that face
would be much lower,
and vice versa.
If you're one of the people
who looks down there,
and we flash up
a face so that it
lands right there
on your retina,
you're much worse
at recognizing it.
And what that means is that
this fundamental problem
that you'll hear
about in the course,
that Tommy has worked
at in many people,
it's one of the central problems
in vision research of how
we deal with the many
different ways an object--
the many different kinds
of images an object
can make on our
retina by where it
lands on the
retina, how close it
is to you, the orientation, the
lighting, all these things that
create this central
problem in vision
of the variable ways
an object can look.
A big part of how we solve
that for face recognition is we
just move our eyes
to the same place.
Position and variance
problem solved, mostly.
OK, it's kind of a
low-tech solution.
It's a good one.
OK, anyway, so Matt has been
working on that for a while,
and so now, most of
that is lab studies.
Now what he's done is he's
using mobile eye trackers, which
look like this, and a
GoPro attached to his head,
because the mobile eye trackers
don't have very good image
resolution.
And so he's sending people
around in the world,
and he's finding that,
first of all, yes, in fact,
when you're walking
around in the world--
not just when you're on a
bike bar in a lab, you know,
with a tracker and a screen--
the people who look up here
also look up there in the world,
right?
So that's just a
reality check that shows
that our technology is working.
And now Matt is using this to
ask all kinds of questions.
For example, social
interactions,
where do people look
in social interactions?
Can you tell stuff
about what they
think about each other based
on where they look on faces,
right?
We want to run--
this is fruity.
We haven't set it
up yet, but we want
to run speed dating
experiments in the lab
with people wearing
eye trackers.
I bet in the first few
fixation positions,
you can tell who's going
to want to recontact who.
I don't know.
We haven't done that yet.
OK, that's a little trashy,
but it's kind of interesting.
Some interesting scientific
questions are a little bit
trashy, you know.
Some trashy questions are not
scientifically interesting.
I think that's one of those
rare that's actually both.
Anyway.
We also want to characterize--
a whole other part of this
is this question that
people have been considering
for a few decades now of
natural image statistics, right?
So people have done all this
stuff, collecting images,
and at first, they did
it really low-tech,
and then the web appeared.
And it's like, oh, now there's
a lot of images out there,
and we can just
collect them easily.
And let's characterize them.
What are natural images like?
So it's a whole
set of math where
people have looked at
those natural images,
and characterized
them, and tried
to ask how the statistical
properties of natural images
have--
how we have adjusted our visual
systems to deal with the images
that we confront.
And that's a cool and
important area of research.
But in all of that
work, nobody's
actually used real
natural images, right?
The images on the web,
somebody stuck a camera
and put it there, and
then they threw away
most of the pictures they took.
The ones that land
on the web are
the ones that have
good resolution, where
people weren't moving in
and out of frame, things
weren't occluded.
They're not at all
like the actual images
that land on your retina.
So we're collecting
the actual images
that land on your retina.
And we're doing it with
mobile eye trackers,
sending people around in the
world using these nice GoPro
systems to give us
high resolution.
And importantly, not only are
we collecting real natural image
statistics from these
real natural images,
we know, for each frame,
where the person was looking.
And that's important for the
reason I mentioned a while ago,
that most of your
high-resolution information
is right at the center of gaze.
And the information out in
the periphery is pretty lousy.
OK, so that's one project
that I described too long,
so I'll whip through
the others more briefly.
We want to know how well people
can read each other's direction
of attention.
OK, so when I'm lecturing now,
if you guys get bored and look
at the clock, I
will see it, right?
And that's just one of
these things, you know?
We're very attuned to where
each other are looking,
and that's very
useful information.
You meet somebody
at a conference,
and you see them make a
saccade down to your name tag,
and it's like, damn it, doesn't
this person remember who I am?
You know?
I'm very aware of this because
I'm mildly prosopagnosic.
So if I've met you before,
and I'm slow to register,
don't take it personally.
I'm just lousy.
It takes me a long
time to encode a face.
Anyway, we're very attuned at
where each other are looking.
And so there's been a lot
of work on how precisely
we can tell whether somebody is
looking right at you versus off
to the side.
Try this at lunch.
When you're in the middle of
a conversation with somebody,
fixate on just the side of their
face, not way off to the side,
just like here, and just
do that for a few seconds.
It's deeply weird.
The person you're talking to
will detect it immediately,
will feel uncomfortable, until
they realize what you're doing,
and then you guys will
have a good laugh.
And that will show you
how exquisitely precise
your ability to read
another person's gaze is.
It's really very
precisely tuned.
OK.
So there's a lot
of work on that,
but there's less
work on how well I
can tell what exactly you're
looking at if it's not me.
That is, I can tell if
you're looking at me or off
to the side, or this
side, or that side.
But what we're
looking at is how well
can I tell what object
you're looking at?
And that's an important
question because many people
have pointed out that a
central little microcosm, kind
of a unit of social
interaction, is something
called joint attention.
And joint attention is when
you're looking at this thing,
and I'm looking at it, and
I know you're looking at it,
and you know I'm looking at it.
That's a cosmic little thing.
Like, we can have this
little moment, right?
Joint attention, OK?
And people have
argued that that's
of the essence in children
learning language.
It's of the essence in all
kinds of social interactions.
And by most accounts,
no other species
has it, not even chimps.
OK?
I mean, there's still
some debate about this,
and people niggle and
stuff, but basically, they
don't have it in anything
like the way we have it.
So we want to know, what is
the acuity of joint attention?
OK, so I was supposed
to do that briefly.
I can't seem to be brief.
OK.
So that's a whole project
that's going on with Danny
Harari and Tao Gao.
We're also asking
how well people
can predict the target of
another person's action, right?
So if I go out to reach
this, at one point-- well,
there's only one
thing there-- but
if we had a whole
array of things,
at one point when I'm
reaching for an object,
can you extrapolate
my trajectory,
look at my eye gaze, and
use all of those cues
to figure out what is
the goal of my action?
Here's a cool way to look
at how well people can
predict each other's actions.
This is work by Maryam
Vaziri-Pashkam, shown here,
who's a post-doc at Harvard
working with Ken Nakayama, who
will give a lecture
later in the course.
And what they're
trying to do is get
an online read of
how well people can
predict each other's actions.
And so obviously, this happens
in all kinds of situations,
especially in sports, right?
If you're playing basketball
or ultimate frisbee,
it's all about predicting
who's going to go where when
and trying to take that into
account with your actions.
So they've set
this up in the lab.
And they have a
piece of glass here,
and there's two Post-its
on this piece of glass.
And one person's task is
to reach out and touch
one of those targets quickly.
And the other person
who's the goalie
watches them through
the glass and tries
to touch that target
as soon as possible
after the first one does.
OK?
And so it's just a
basic little game.
And so they have little
sensors on each person's finger
so they can track the
exact trajectories
and get reaction times.
They're just behavioral
measurements,
but they're very cool.
So what they find
first of all is
that the goalie,
the person who's
trying to reach to respond
to the other person,
can do that extremely
fast, right?
They launch their hand
to the correct target
within 150 milliseconds.
Well, you should immediately
realize that something's fishy.
You can't do that.
It takes about 100
milliseconds just to get to V1.
It takes, I forget how long,
but a few tens of milliseconds
to send the signal
out from your brain
out your arm to
initiate the movement.
So how could you possibly
do all of that in that time?
Well, you can't.
And what that means is
that people are actually
launching the hand
action, the goalie's
launching the action before
the other person has actually
started moving their finger.
They've started
processing it before.
And the way they've done that
is before this person starts,
before their hand
moves at all, they've
subtly changed their body
configuration in ways
that the other person can read.
OK?
Now, on the one hand, OK, duh.
You're playing this game.
You learn to exploit cues.
We're really great at figuring
out cues quickly, and using
them, and learning to use them.
But here's the--
one second-- here's
the cool thing
about this task is
that this immediate, ultrafast
reaction time happens
on the very first few trials.
So the ability that this
task is tapping into
is not that the goalie can learn
what cues are predictive given
enough trials and feedback.
No, they do it
right off the bat.
This task is tapping
into an ability
that we all have
already, right now,
to read each other's actions and
predict each other's behavior.
And so people with no
instruction and no experience
whatsoever in this
novel task know
that this subtle little cue
of the way the body is moving
a little bit before the person's
finger even starts to move,
they can tell what
it's predictive of.
So that's just another way to
characterize people's abilities
in social perceptions,
so one of some
of the many different things
that we just see really
well in other people's actions.
OK, that's what I
just said, all right.
All right.
I'm going to skip
over some stuff.
We're looking at perception
of emotional expressions.
Almost the entire
literature is based
on staged emotional
expressions on faces,
huge literature with
neuroimaging and behavior,
and it goes back forever.
But my colleague Elinor
McKone has pointed out
that actually, it would
be important to look
at real emotional
expressions on faces.
Maybe that's different
behaviorally.
It turns out it's very
different behaviorally.
One, you can tell if somebody's
faking an emotional expression
or if it's a real one.
Like, OK, which of these is
real fear, and which of these
is staged fear?
Duh!
OK, so one, we're
really attuned to that.
I think that's
really interesting.
Just as a social
perceptual ability,
we spend a lot of time trying
to figure out who's sincere,
who's genuine, who's
faking something,
what's for real, right?
You know?
There's all kinds
of shades of that.
And here's one little
piece of it, right?
So I think that's
very interesting.
And they've shown that
behaviorally, these phenomenon
are very different.
Just one example.
A prior literature had shown
that people with schizophrenia
are particularly bad at
reading facial expressions,
using the standard measures, a
standard stimuli, the Ekman six
facial expressions.
These guys replicated that
finding and then showed
that when you run
the same experiment,
but using not staged but
real emotional expressions,
schizophrenics are better
than everyone else.
OK, so it matters behaviorally,
and it's interesting.
OK.
All right.
Other things that we're doing--
right.
Leyla, your TA here, who's done
beautiful work on her thesis
work with Tommy using
MEG and other methods,
is now working with
me and Gabriel,
using some of this
magnificent data
that Gabriel has collected over
a bunch of years, where he's
got intracranial recordings
from human brains
while people watch movies.
This is so precious.
These data are
like a dream to me,
as somebody who's
been using functional
MRI as my main hammer
for the last 15 years.
Functional MRI is magnificent,
it's wonderful, it's fun,
but it has fundamental limits.
One, it has no time
information worth a damn.
And the computations
that make up perception,
including social perception, and
language processing, and most
of the interesting
aspects of cognition,
happen on the order of
tens of milliseconds.
We can't see any of that.
It's all just squashed
together like a pancake, right,
with functional MRI.
With intracranial recordings,
you have exquisite time
information, and you can see
computations unfold over time.
That's very precious.
Second of all, in principle,
with intracranial electrodes,
you can test causality,
something you
can't do with functional MRI.
You can stimulate and ask
what tasks are disrupted.
All right?
So there's a huge
number of cool things
you can do with
intracranial recordings.
Leyla is looking
at some of the data
that Gabriel has
been collecting,
with intracranial recordings
of people watching movies.
And because these are rich,
complex social stimuli,
she's going to look
at all kinds of things
that we can try to
extract from those data.
Like, can you tell the
identity of the person
who's on the screen right now?
Can you tell from their face,
their voice, their body?
Can you tell what action
they're carrying out?
Can you tell if the
person on the screen right
now is a good guy or a bad guy?
Right?
Can you tell what kind of social
interactions are going on?
So we know all of this
stuff, all this information
is extracted in the brain,
because people are good at it.
But to get a handle on the
actual neural basis of how
we carry out those
perceptual processes,
this will be a really cool tool.
So that project is
just starting now.
And in other projects going
on, Lindsey Powell, shown here,
who's working with Rebecca Saxe,
and Liz Spelke, and others,
is using this NIRS
method to look
at blood flow
changes in response
to neural activity
in infant brains.
She's looking at some
of those specializations
that I showed you in my
brain at the beginning
and asking, which of those
are present in infancy,
a totally cool question.
And Ben Deen, and Rebecca Saxe,
and me, and a bunch of others
are looking at a big chunk of
the human brain that was one
of my colored patches before.
This whole dark gray
region here is called
the superior temporal sulcus.
This is an inflated
picture of the brain.
That means--
usually, the cortexes
are all folded up
inside the head.
You have to do that
to fit it in there.
But if you want to
see the whole thing,
you can mathematically
inflate it.
So that's what's happened here.
And the dark bits are the
bits that were inside of folds
before it was inflated.
So they're inside
a sulcus, but now
shown blown out to the surface.
So this superior temporal
sulcus running down here
is one of the longest
sulci in the human brain
and one of the coolest.
And an awful lot of social
perception goes on right there.
Ben Deen has a paper in
press and some ongoing work
where he shows that
lots of different kinds
of social, cognitive,
and perceptual abilities
actually inhabit
somewhat distinct regions
along the superior
temporal sulcus.
They're not perfectly discrete.
Nothing is a neat little
oval in the brain.
Actually, they somewhat
overlap, but there's
a lot of organization in there.
And that's cool
because it gives us
a lever to try to understand
this whole big space
of cognition.